Speaker 1: Things are very rapidly escalating
in Russia. We've been waiting and wondering,
well, what is Putin's eventual move here? What was
expected by some to be an extremely rapid, total
defeat of Ukraine, of course, did not happen.
And over the last couple of weeks, we have seen
Russian forces actually repelled and retreating.
And the question amid continued concerns about
Vladimir Putin's health, has been what is the end
game? How is he going to ultimately get out of
this or is he ultimately going to get out of this?
The U.S. embassy is now warning Americans to get
out of of Russia. This is the clearest declaration
and the most comprehensive of you just have to
get out. Now, many of you might be saying, why are
there Americans still in Russia? There are so many
different reasons why there are Americans still
in Russia. And we're going to talk about that in
a moment. A CNN reporting the US embassy in Moscow
issued a security alert overnight that again urged
U.S. citizens to leave Russia immediately. While
there are still options for departing the country.
The alert comes in the wake of Russian President
Putin's order for partial mobilization of Russian
men to fight in his war in Ukraine. Quote,
Russia may refuse to acknowledge dual nationals,
US citizenship, deny their access to US consular
assistance, prevent their departure from Russia
and conscript dual nationals for military service.
That is a really scary statement which we will
talk about. The embassy has consistently warned
Americans not to travel to Russia and to depart
the country immediately if there. The embassy
alert urged U.S. citizens to, quote, avoid all
political or social protests. Do not photograph
security personnel at these events, noting that
the right to peaceful assembly and freedom of
expression are not guaranteed in Russia. Very
different situation that Americans in Russia have
to understand. Leaving is a very good idea at this
point, but at the same time, there are people who
simply didn't research the situation properly, who
are there. Now, one of the things that's important
to understand about the dual citizenship thing. If
you are in a country in which you hold citizenship
and you hold an additional citizenship,
meaning you are an American citizen and you
are a Russian citizen, and you are in Russia.
It is often the case that in that country you are
only viewed through the lens of that citizenship.
If you were a French-American dual citizen and
you were in Russia. This is not an issue if you
are an American, Russian, dual citizen and you
were in Russia. The American citizenship isn't
particularly relevant, at least not as far as
Russia cares. If you are a Russian-American dual
citizen and you're in Russia and Russia says,
Hey, you know what? We are we are conscripting
individuals to fight in the military. And you
go, Oh, no, I need help from the American embassy
because I'm also an American citizen. It is very
common that that will be denied to you. Now, the
American authorities might say, well, we can still
try to help, but you will often be denied consular
services because at the end of the day, you are a
Russian citizen. And this is something that I've
talked about and thought about in other terms with
regard to my Argentinean dual citizenship, where
there have been discussions of what if X, Y or
Z happened while in Argentina. This is obviously
much more serious and much more significant. Now,
some reactions I've read are more or less like,
shouldn't these Americans have already left? I'm
actually I'm sympathetic to the people that are
there and that are also American citizens. It
is really difficult to uproot your life. There
are lots of people whose entire lives, despite
being American, Russian, dual citizens, their
entire lives are in Russia. They were born in the
U.S. to Russian parents and went to Russia at age
three. Okay. That's that's an American citizen,
not nominally, whose entire life is arguably in
Russia. And so the idea of, well, just get out,
what are you doing there? It's a more complicated
statement than that might appear. The other thing
about this is that not everybody has the money or
financial resources to get out and to come back to
the United States. It may not be obvious how they
would make a living in the United States. If you
are working in Russia and this is often something
that comes up when we talk about undocumented
immigration to the United States and many on
the right love to pretend that people that come to
the United States illegally kind of doing it on a
whim, kind of doing it for fun, for entertainment,
almost like some kind of tourism of some sense.
And what's often missing from that conversation
is that these are people's lives. And uprooting
or moving your life to a different country is a
really, really big deal. And so even when you are
coming to the United States undocumented from
Central South America looking for work, as is
this typical situation that we talk about, that's
a massive decision that no one makes lightly. And
it's often missing total lack of empathy when
we talk about and think about what it is that
these folks are doing here, not related to, hey,
Americans, it's time to get out of Russia. But
that also is going on. But these folks are not
on vacation is the important thing to understand.
And this now gets us back to what is Putin
willing to do? How far is Putin willing to
go? What is he potentially considering? And
is Putin sick? Is Putin erratic? Is Putin not
thinking clearly? And the answers to all of these
questions may well be, yes. So there are some very
non-trivial decisions to be made by Americans in
Russia. And the next 4 to 6 weeks of what Putin
does or doesn't do could be extremely important in
terms of the entire course that this war is going
to take. Scary moment. And yes, all other caveats
aside, people have lives. People are all all these
things that we've talked about for people living
in Russia, the recommendation is to get out.
My preference would be not to end up potentially
conscripted into the Russian army. Now, of course,
I am not a Russian dual citizen and I have no
connections to Russia. So it's easy for me to say